la Société d'assurance automobile du
Québec va suspendre automatiquement le
permis de conduire d'une personne
souffrant de troubles neuro cognitifs
qu'ils soient léger ou grave auparavant
un médecin pouvait informer la SAAQ que
détenteur de permis de conduire
présentait un diagnostic de trouble
neuro-cognitif et nécessitait une
évaluation mais le problème c'est qu'en
attendant les résultats de cette
évaluation il n'y avait pas de
révocation immédiate du permis il y
avait de la confusion il y a des gens
qui conduisaient quand même en pensait
qu'il pouvait quand même conduire
lorsqu'on fait maintenant c'est que dès
qu'on a un diagnostic de troupes
cognitif on suspend le permis de la
personne pour plusieurs médecins dans ce
gériatre cette mesure est trop brutale
un des impacts c'est que ça va empêcher
certaines personnes qui en ont encore
les capacités de conduire un véhicule
avec les conséquences que ça peut avoir
sur leur autonomie et leur qualité de
vie ce des plat aussi le manque de
communication de la part de la SAQ comme
j'ai rien puis Dieu sait si j'en suis
des patients qui ont des troubles neuro
cognitifs puis que les enjeux de
conduite automobile ça fait partie de
notre quotidien nous avons rien reçu à
cet effet là comme personnage et c'est
important encore d'avoir sa voiture en
se sent tellement autonome c'est tout un
problème c'est
la qualité de vie cette dame qui ne
souffre pas de troubles cognitifs
exprime très bien l'angoisse de
plusieurs personnes âgées mais la SAQ
dit agir pour des questions de sécurité
pour la sécurité oui d'accord avec eux
la sax se défend d’être trop sévère avec
cette mesure en disant qu'une personne
qui est atteinte de troubles neuro
cognitifs et qui vient de perdre son
permis de conduire peut toujours en
appeler de cette décision et demander
une nouvelle évaluation de son état
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada
Montréal